Mom Carolyn I called Neda and.
I'm the director of research center in virtual reality called emerging analytics center
and we are part of the University of Arkansas in the talk
and a lot of people ask why are you in the third Rock Arkansas doing something that is so much.
Then we can advance and mother
and the reason for it is because this is a tremendously good infrastructure here to do what I do
and that is actually a lot of energy and enthusiasm to support the work that I do
and they're producing it is for us to do.
Interesting projects and more unique things with less restrictions not knowing so much.
Legal restrictions but almost intellectual restrictions you know because here. There is almost nothing so.
So there is no preconceptions there is no baggage of any kind.
You know there is no things have to be done in a certain way so to me that's always been very exciting you know.
It's new and and and we are the cool group on the compass you know where the exciting group on campus
and for me it's always a good thing.
And so
and this is not the first time in my career I have always been in universities where you would not respect to have the
kind of work that I do
and this really like us is a lot more fun is harder too because we run into some complications we don't have a lot of
colleagues. That we can talk to or an environment.
Were there is a lot of knowledge on the area that we do research of
but at the same time it's a lot of fun because like I said we have no constraints of any kind on what we do.
Pretty much you know we're kind of. By union into some a stand and we hear our head. In the wall.
We had to hear and hear and hear
and eventually we break the world because like I say sometimes we're entirely on our own in some situations
but at the same time because we are unique group in the campus
and in many cases in the state that we are in in the United States.
Then we get a lot of support and we get a lot of encouragement
and we get a lot of positive reactions to a lot of the things that we do.
And also we give a large part because around us we are always generating other opportunities for example.
Businesses that will now consider coming into Little Rock.
They consider setting up here because we are here so for them having a relationship with my group.
Might be very exciting
and they were like Oh we know we're not thinking of going to Arkansas we were thinking of maybe going to California
or Boston or something like that but your group being they are.
Is is for us is actually wonderful because the cost of living is a lot lower the ability for us to financially support
the company is is much much easier than the disorder areas
and at the same time have we have the same intellectual quality on our relationship with our universities so much of
the beneficial relationship for us to be in in one aspect of a university.
What it's all is my science I don't know a lot of people ask me that question
and I'm not sure if I'm actually a scientist myself because I'm more training from engineering
and engineers were always sort of the We Are Scientists because we're always very practical. So.
I think our science is more.
Our ability to find the root of our problem and find some ways to solve the problem or at least to make a better man
or be deeply deeply theoretical a lot of the things that we do
but they are deeply technically challenging the things that we do so.
Sometimes is a struggle because we might be doing something that is unique.
Nobody has done it before is incredibly hard to solve the problem.
But in my now feel that we just discover a new way of how the galaxies were formed.
You know or or some new philosophy cow theory of how our soul relates to the. Universe or something like that.
You know. So we are we are much more practical and down to and a specific point that needs a solution so but what.
Yes I have my theories and myself personally I think.
So on my entire career I have been a little bit of an outsider to the virtual reality science community because I
always thought differently than the main trend of thoughts. Even today.
You know if you talk about virtual reality today
when somebody says do you know what virtual reality is about immediately they're going to identify with put in some
sort of goggles on your face. And look around some beautiful landscape or something like that.
That's not exactly what I do because to me virtual reality is the ability to create some world in the computer that
again solves a problem. And in order to do that sometimes you have to be multiple people share in the environment.
With their own bodies not not sort of virtual representation of myself in the world but actually myself physically
and better in the virtual world so I want to see your face and your face
and your face while I'm seeing the virtual world. So my work is more about building larger.
Well when when again when you talk about virtual reality with the majority of the community with the body.
But I do here. I'm going to tell you what happened to me when I first overture reality.
Let's go back to the beginning you know when I first saw virtual reality in one nine hundred ninety one.
I had the same experience everybody is having today.
You know somebody put some goggles on my face and I started looking around some beautiful world.
And of course I was a young student at the time
and never seen it before so why did I do the same as everybody does today.
You know
but like with everything else after that it's all over the excitement is over then you start thinking What is this
thing really what is this thing. You know what what us and again I'm thinking as an engineer.
What is this thing doing for me other than just wow. So when I start thinking. First of all our US.
You know I'm not myself anymore. Here. Because when I'm in right here in this room with you. I see my hands.
I see my legs. I see a little bit of my hearing here. When I put goggles. I lost all that immediately.
I'm not myself anymore.
I don't know how big something is I don't know how close something is because I can tell this table this year because I.
And see my hand going towards the table so that gives me a sense of space
and relationship in the virtual world I'm trying to grab something.
But I don't see anything at the most I see some floating hand that is not connected to my body
and is not even my own hand because most of the virtual environments.
They give you a male hand you know
and I'm a woman I have a little redness I know that's not even my hand so I lose myself their mom
and I walk in there were charges because that's number one number two.
As humans we like to talk to people we are very social individuals were very social. I don't know. I put my goggles on.
I lost all of you as well because I might be seeing something
and I might be sent look at that you don't see because you don't have the guy was on what I see you don't see that
there's no way for me to share that with you in the same way I shared this room with you.
So to me those those kinds of things since I was very very very young were very unknowing about the way virtual reality
was being approached by in general by the research community.
So so I thought about what can be done to bring myself into the virtual space.
What can I do to do that and I was very fortunate because I was a start in my Ph D.
On the professor that I was working away it gave me a lot of freedom to explore whatever I wanted to do.
He has some say ideas of what he wanted to do.
And I was I started doing what he wanted me to do
but at the same time in part of that I started spending mending with some of the scenes that I was interested on
and on the line. The professor was gracious enough to recognise that the direction that I was going in was exciting.
Let me run with those ideas. So I end up developing. In a sense a goggle big enough that it was the size of a room.
So instead of putting that on your head. Yeah I build a case. A student used today not twenty something years later.
So so you walk into this room so because your body comes with you into the virtual environment your friends come with
you into a better environment and you'll see that tomorrow when we got to the laboratory you know so you come with me.
And then I would be saying Look at Dan.
And you see my finger pointing at a virtual object the same way I say look at this table or something like that.
So the social element is part of the virtual spin as without any recreate virtually of yourself which is what people do
these days when you share a virtual environment. They recreate yourself in the virtual environment. But that's not you.
That's a puppet represents you or an avatar. I guess the right term.
So for me like I said back in one thousand nine hundred one.
You know everybody's going this way in virtual reality
and I'm going that way so that has been always a little bit challenging to be.
It was well it does what I mentioned earlier you know I have been very very successful on what I have done
but my work has been always been recognised as science because it doesn't feed the pattern
or the moment that the community is the majority of the community is going
but at the same time there were that I have done has had a significant impact in the industry today.
A lot of the car companies for example have caves a different stages of the design and manufacturing of cars.
They are industry uses of the cave not the cave us it was originally created but.
But this concept of having large spaces that you share the mercy of a space.
And many others you know for training and in many other aspects is not is not a commodity
or a consumer product you know it's not something that you can have in your home obviously
but body has been incredibly successful.
Another industry that has quite a lot and is not very well known in the press is the mining industry
or safety training underground mines are. The Sunni complex and have a lot of safety issues around the world.
Those are the marine trainers.
And I think that's the main contribution to this work because in the minds of many people for maybe ten fifteen years.
Virtual reality was a particular platform and my world to say virtual reality is a concept
and that concept can be realized in a variety of platforms and is not one platform is a solution.
There are different problems. Depending on the program platform for similar problems. This place is a good platform.
But some of the problems. You see it in the lab all the kind of platforms are.
More appropriate question maybe four years ago when virtual reality was not popular.
The answer would be different today virtual reality is very popular.
Again it was very popular in the ninety's and then he went silent and it's popular again
and I think the reason to do it is I guess.
The students that come and study with me something related to virtual reality
and in particular if they work with me because of my name recognition then they'll get a good job
and they'll make a lot of money. So those kind of students to be honest with you. I don't wonder.
So students in my lab
and we have learned very quickly to spot students because they don't really care about their work in their minds they
think oh I'm doing something that is trendy and and just because I'm doing it
and just because I'm doing you know I'm just going to graduate and I'm just going to get this high paying job
but from from experience about what they're doing they care about making money at the end.
So we care about those when they come to us and they say can I work with you because I have this idea
and I think with your guidance I could explore this idea. And so that's an example of a student.
That would like to find us because that's how I was you know I was doing something nobody had done it before
and I had a professor that for. Andris another decided to let me run with a you know what is right or a holiday.
Oh OK Well then what i normally. Plenty of people is just a way to create worlds with a computer. Now for me.
That is very little difference between virtual reality and augmented reality.
There are two fields and
when you talk to different professionals there will be people there will be very very adamant that is true completely
different disciplines you know you do virtual reality you know nothing mental reality. And so on.
There are some other groups are not part of those clothes
but I've seen both of them have a lot of common base concepts.
And the differences with virtual reality you create worlds that are entirely in the computer.
They don't necessarily have any relationship to the real world
or too little reality that you find yourself in that particular moment so you can be tiny tiny tiny tiny
and explore the world at the atomic level or you can be huge and explore a universe level you can travel.
Worlds that never system you can go back in time you can go into the future. So basically.
Whatever your imagination conceives you can generate that inside the computer.
And then put yourself inside out for a while and that's a very good question for many of the words that we do there.
To the people that experience those words there is something that we study that is called The sense of presence.
So how how much does virtual worlds make you in a sense forget that their virtual
and your sanity became so involved so engaged on the world that that world becomes real so you forget what that you are
inside a company or something like that and you're completely get. Mentally and almost physically transported to that.
New Reality whatever it is you know.
So so
and that's what we want to do sometimes we really want to feel that those places are real whether you're there for five
minutes
or three hours that you disconnect yourselves from the real world sometimes are very disoriented because we make worlds
that intentionally don't behave like with the laws of physics as the real world US
and is very interesting sometimes to see people are just in worlds you know because the something like for example as
you know you see in the you have as there is going to happen in sound if you're going downstairs
and you don't even know what happened.
So we we have some words like that that you saw in the the laws of physics don't work
but people become very functional just like they always did that.
It makes a lot of sense that you're going up the stairs and Sally you end up in the basement.
You know you go up stairs to go to the basement is just normal you know.
So it's to me you know these kinds of things are very exciting in of course sometimes on that particular moment on that
particular time frame that you are in the space you might become very real.
We have people that are afraid sometimes to move in the virtual space because we have our floor is also.
So sometimes we might be Betty high up another edge of something
or maybe one of the prices that we have right now has one of those rope
and boards bridges that you have to cross between two very high mountains.
And we have people that want to cross that bridge because they're afraid of heights me personally.
No no it's for me as is sometimes because I've been doing this for so long.
Sometimes it's hard for me to disconnect myself from the real reality so I know I know in a sense IS NOT REAL FAKE to
some extent. No I can I walk on water and I feel like.
I mean the visions Yes but
but we do have a lot of people that think twice before they go through this through that again with my how about going
to that doesn't have any rating.
You know a lot of people will not do that a step to get out of the balcony which nothing is going to happen I mean
they're just going to the ground but virtually they are not on time so we have people that even if we push them
and they will be jammed they said give it a try. No no. So it's a becomes four it becomes very very real and people do.
They have this is strange to out of confusion in their heads they know it's not real but they behave like this real.
So it's a very interesting. While again like I told at the beginning.
Problems through virtual reality one probably never saw in all the time is different types of training. Yes virtual.
Yes And it's also it's also a way to sometimes communicate. Your understanding of the world to others.
For example we have worked with patients that have brain damage that has changed the way they perceive the world
and how they. How they function. You know for us is very easy to look at this table and we know immediately said table.
You know.
For people have some kind of brain damage through accidents or some disease or something and they look at the table
and they cannot recognize that this is a table for example you know.
So sometimes the behavior feels erratic but it's not erratic because they find themselves in situations that.
Just something as simple as a table that the brain doesn't process.
So we have worked with some patients a few years back through their verbal descriptions of how they perceive the world
we try to recreate virtual environments that we could become that person
and we could understand how that person perceives the world and why that person has a panic attack
when there's a tree on the path because it does not recognize that you know so those consensus.
Is Yeah you can help people to understand your reality in a sense in a way you know.
And again you can also create and completely new reality that we don't know what these nominees. You might imagine.
And Bill then and make a spin and I have a good colleague.
That he's sort of perspective is that virtual reality allows you to be not only somebody else but something else.
So he always gives the example he always wanted to be a lobster. So you know.
He's like one of his first virtual over twenty something years ago West to understand the world from the perspective of
a lobster and you use virtual reality and become a lobster. You know so. That's not really my my work. It's more.
From a practical perspective. How do we solve a problem.
You know certainly you know
when I feel the world like let's say you were some sort of bacteria bacteria sender stand there world
and how do they spread themselves through another organism Well you can use virtual reality and become a bacteria.
And live in the world of microorganisms and see how the world. When you try to. And I see in there is a little bit of.
I would say every new science there is always positive part of the science brings to society.
And some of the potential that can bring into society and certainly that is a concern that.
We might create some realities that become much.
More pleasant much more rewarding
or satisfactory a real reality especially in the world that we live today many frustrations you know we all have a lot
of frustrations in our daily life and then you can going to virtual reality and you can be
but he was the person with a beautiful virtual yacht going to some beautiful virtual island that you now are not you
are a small tiny basement apartment that you can barely paid rent you know.
So there is certainly a concern and it's a growing concern that we might.
In the long term in the long term future not not in the next maybe five years
but really looking fine into the future that we might create this reality to some extent that is better than our real
reality and we my all in start living more those outer net realities versus the real life or something.
And how within one hundred and that at this moment we are I think so early on what we are doing that.
I don't think none of us has a baby
and I have to say understanding our picture of how all this is going to happen because right now with the technology
that we have I am personally convinced that will never really happen because the technology is still with what the way
we have it right now we have and we have and I don't think we have found the right solution at all.
All the platforms that we have right now.
And right now I'm talking about physical platforms you know that if I have met all the different projects all the
different all these things that we have they are not like transparent.
You know it takes a conscious effort to put them on you have to have. A specific. Technology computers.
You know it's not comfortable it doesn't feed well on your head it crashes.
You know all those kinds of things so so it is a good novelty. But I think that as we move forward.
People will like all the novelties you know and in a couple of years.
Everybody will come down
and then everybody is going to have their virtual reality set at the bottom of the drawer where like has happened with
some of the gaming technologies that you know the way. I again with the current platforms as we have them today.
I think so because again there were some gaming platforms which I'm not going to mention that they were going to change.
They were going to change the world a few years ago. And what happened.
Yes it was a great innovation
but who wants to spend three four five six hours playing a video game standing on your feet you know it was a radical
platform. Yeah and that's what I say with the technology that I have today.
Now but in the direction that we're going whatever might come down the line you know certain concerns
and there are starting to be around the world. Movements related to Essex and the use of virtual reality.
So there are some you know starting there is some here in the U.S.
Some in Europe that are starting to appear there are some in Asia where at this moment are being more kind of like
coffee shop conversations you know a small group but they are starting to a P.R. Because that is that is a concern.
Now at the same time is a concern to say hey we should stop doing what we're doing or not. Do it anymore.
I don't think so because the benefits are so much
and some many levels that this is something that is more education you know like drugs you know everybody knows that
drugs are bad but people are still taking drugs. That's their own responsibility to make that decision.
So there's always something
but on the other hand you know it's also good because we also have done some work related to a stress and depression.
And again in this reality there for a short period of time. Again some person whatever is your fantasy. A famous.
Famous explorer going somewhere you know a love story. You know whatever your fantasy.
Just just ten fifteen minutes exposure to that type of reality.
Significantly cress decreases stress levels and depressions.
And that has been demonstrated by not only another you know I would have I would. Well we have thought today.
I mean look at what people are doing in Facebook is a you in Facebook is not really you I mean you are the one doing
the postings but you are in a sense you know maybe exaggerating some of your postings.
Not necessarily lying but embellish the situation.
So we are ready to some extent are using some technologies that are multiple personalities
or multiple identities you know a lot of discussions on how people represent themselves in chat rooms and in Twitter
and some other things and so I think.
Of course with virtual reality is much more powerful because it's not just your post in a picture
and say oh look big deal about this you know but it's actually live in that they are actually creating
or something like that.
So I don't know personally that something that doesn't worry me to march because again the benefits are really in many
ways maybe happier and healthier because you know as we're getting older.
For example you know we don't have as much energy as we used to have
but by my one of my identities can be a very energetic woman that kind of still go
and you know down some point shoes which I have been dancing over thirty years now.
You know but you know I kind of still virtually maybe do that you know maybe your other just to go and swim.
You know ten kilometers or something. You know how close a straight.
Somewhere and you cannot do that right now but that virtual reality might have argued to do it you know.
So I think it's. As.
Well we're also going to have life is going to change too because again some of the things that virtual reality helps
like any other again new technologies to I think their way we work is going to change so as we are all having more
right now we're in a strange in my opinion transmission technology we are having a lot of technologies that make our
jobs but at the same time do more work. You know like for example e-mail e-mail communications tremendously.
But at the same time we're communicating in a lot more so.
So we can never we're always busy trying to clear our email you know so we communicate so much.
Now that it's keeping us again looking into the future and many of these things get resolved
and that translates into us having all their time that we can use for more quality time of something else. I mean.
So I think maybe in the future virtual reality is going to help us to do our normal everyday work life easier in some
ways you know like with companies for example that in the last ten years timeframe from the concept of a product to the
pro the been in the market.
In between seven
and nine years with the introduction of virtual reality the way in virtual test in virtual prototyping bringing
customers on the virtual. There's cycle now has for about two years.
So that that has released a lot of the people in the company a tremendous amount of work that they can use for
something else you know so I don't know.
Hard to imagine future
but at the same time I think we could potentially be a more relaxed future because again it's a few minutes of escapin
you know I love the ocean and we don't live by the ocean. We live in the ME that of Arkansas right now.
You know so it would be great if I could spend thirty minutes every day
and feeling the breeze you know that alone would just be happy for the rest of the afternoon.
You know just kind of hear like a humane and spend six months in the ocean or something.
You know I don't know I think well of course of course because well the same as when you do in life.
I mean the reality is not a pass. If reality is an active reality in real life. You don't see. You.
You have to do things you know you have to open a can of Coke. You have to turn on the lights.
You have to look at the window. You have to do something. No no no. You mean be glad your physical. Needs.
Yes you're my other no it will be.
I don't think anybody has done any size and I'm assuming that you know or thirsty or wanted to go to the restroom
or something that I would probably still in the virtual reality.
We'll override some of our basic survival instincts or something like that
and I will be surprised if that happens you know we talk about them
but I don't think you can do a version of the space. You don't feel hungry or something like that. You know and.
This is the I mean there are there are then there are others that actually develop virtual taste
and Virtual the smells you know also potentially potentially you my.
Be in the virtual environment and just have virtual taste of the food and actually not being anything
but I still think that it is so more the basic survival instance The sooner
or later stomach it's going to be like OK this virtual taste is delicious but my tummy still has not received.
I think that we can fake a lot like I tell you we get people that they will not walk off a balcony in a virtual
environment you know so that's. That's a survival instinct that the real time I don't naturally.
So well again it depends on how reality is really on the virtual world you know because we can make you fall down
and we can bank you know a motion platform or put you in some kind of device that actually makes you feel the fall
and actually hurt yourself if you. When I got to that level. So in my lab we don't do that right now.
You know
but in previous locations that I was before we actually had robotic type of systems that were around your body.
And as you were interact in the virtual space the robotics were giving you physical feedback of the world.
You know so in those pretty nicely. Yeah yeah. So you could actually touch of our challenge at Anfield.
Or you could grab something and feel the weight of that one child not you so again depending on how real is reality.
You can actually make it happen but assuming again with the technology that we have today.
You know there are some some instance that again we trigger with our necessarily intentionally do it
when we build the worlds but we observe that when we have people.
I were I want to spaces you know so sometimes we don't realize something and then
when we have people in our virtual spaces we're not these things and when I was with think about that one.
You know because like I said earlier there's a lot of things we don't now.
Yet we don't understand yet what this technology really does to our head. You know this coarseness we're just.
Because we try to explore the borders of science was what is the future. When you. Please. So.
You can create a new identity for yourself. Because it makes reality.
And they might become for for for you or for me or for other people.
The reality that you prefer to be versus the reality you know and.
And as you know that has been around in science fiction for a long time.
You know I mean there are for example Asimov has a few novels where.
It's a society in which humans don't want to have face to face contact anymore because they prefer the virtual contact
you know is to them almost a physical contact. They don't want to do that anymore. You know.
So certainly like I say earlier you know.
Pessimistic extreme side of things you know maybe we cannot our way of thinking and nothing will happen.
I am positive way.
It's Yeah you know hey if you're if your virtual reality makes you a better person makes you enjoy your life better
then Lieberman was what's the big deal about it. You know I don't know. Right. So.
I think my personal opinion is probably yes because again this is an identity that you are creating a digitally in a
computer. So you can decide how much. You let others do.
Influence your identity versus you have full control of your identity again at a very simplistic level.
You know look at people doing social media you know some of us share everything with the entire world
and we let the world sort of in a sense influence how we appear to the world in our social media
and some of us have a lot of restrictions where we have a very limited group of people like
and influence our conversations and
and in that way maybe we don't necessarily are inform of everything else that happens because we don't do a so that's a
simplistic level but again it's is a digital reality. So you can define. In the future.
You can say you know I want to be a virtual Harmeet. So my reality is mine and mine alone.
And I just don't want anybody else to distort it or to some a stand.
You know or you know hey I have a really cool reality and I want to share that with my friends
or with the rest of the world.
You know and let us see how these but this goes you know because I let other people evolve it with me
and see where the so I think everything at this moment is an open.
Possibility again mediated by the again thinking as an engineer mediated by how we build the tools and the systems
and the platforms and all those kinds of things to make these things happen because today is not possible.
And normal person is not at the level of technology that we have
and other people around the world as you know they cannot do that right now.
You know it's not it's not very easy to create these realities right.
You have to have a certain training to be able to do it you know. In a body for the future. Yes.
Yeah well if I can the rest for a moment I'm going to talk about a little bit where you are mentioning right now
because that's something that right now is a baby concern of mine a personal concern that I have which is the many
people today are virtual reality developer experts.
You know because everybody today has a computer because gaming industry has very very clearly everybody has a fairly
good computer at home that can do pretty good graphics pretty good and he mentions on those kinds of things you know.
So there are some tools out there are our open source
or free license tools that people can get their hands on the B.B.C.
and Now suddenly were seen all these virtual reality experts popping up everywhere because they seen that because they
grab the tool they do a few pretty three D. Models and they put it on Google carb or for example you know.
Oh I'm very close to reality. While I this is something that is have a frustration of mine because this is not.
There's many other things behind that because I mean you guys are producing a documentary.
So you know everybody nowadays can get a digital camera.
But I'm going to produce a documentary of the level of quality that you're going to do
and know because you know I the fact that I can get to come. I should have somebody face on hold. That is that.
Doesn't mean that doesn't make me a good director.
You know because that is all that lights that is the question is that you're making me and
and this business that we all have.
The same thing happens in virtual reality and you can get a tool
but do you know what your parameters are you know they're. Oh absolutely.
I mean for example if you're generating a world there is a certain speed which the world needs to be presented to the
user or there was a user plain and simple.
He's going to get really really really sick right of the
but now many many people don't understand that they just start putting three D. Worlds in the three D.
Models and they have a horrible performance. That are not even synchronized one eye is going this way or the other.
You know
and my issue is that the US does kinds of applications sometimes aren't the first virtual reality perience for many
people and we are starting to see more
and more people coming in our laboratory saying oh no I don't want to try a thing here.
I already tried to react and it made me very very sick. You know. So there's this immediate rejection.
And I'm like well you know I'm not a high school that just got my hands on free license something and a slap together.
A pretty model. You know we have been doing this.
Betty scientifically very consciously with all the right approach and constraints and years
and years of experience of place try not to. And that is unfortunate. I happened in my own on my own more.
And now these are things that we've been talking about will now happen if this other thing continues proliferate
because if this period see the people are negative experiences there's going to be rejection
and that happened back in the ninety's.
Yes So I was mentioned to you and I do talk a lot around the world about what I do
and also my virtual reality is going to go
and I am pretty convinced that we're living in one of those human history changing times right now.
We don't see it because we're living generations into the future.
You know maybe two hundred years from now three hundred years from now people of my time a virtual reality revolution
the industrial revolution
and the information revolution I think we have a point I think it's going to change our world as we know are going to
change how we leave us humans and how humans.
And of course we don't know it because we're living in right now
but I again I'm pretty convinced in a few hundred years or no.
We'll be on the textbooks
and say you know the twenty fifteen to twenty twenty is was the peak of the virtual reality revolution were all this
was happening you know. It's hard to imagine how the future is going to look like but I think I think you're right.
Try and there we are I think. I'm doing a lot of things.
I mean right now the things that I cannot do because of physical limitations.
What I might be doing well you know I would be right now and saying you know is super hot at this particular moment
and I really want to reach in five seconds. You know and. I'm going to go. I'm going to go in the beach.
I'm going to the ocean. I'm going to smell the beautiful salty.
And I'm going to forget about all these forgiveness and humidity of July in Arkansas for whatever time I'm in there.
My child my decide that he wants to go to some amusement park but I don't have the time to physically take him there.
Or maybe. We don't have the finances to go.
They are my son my say OK Mommy I'm just going to go par for the next two hours or the mother me. You know.
So I think that was that's an example or my car just broke down and I have no idea how to fix this car you know
but I'm just going to go into some reality that is just going to somehow how me fix that car and get a better.
You know
or since I cannot go with my real car then I'm going to go into some virtual reality what I'm going to go what I was
going to go up and I cannot go you know so I think that is going to be.
You know I tend to tell them to tell people that we can do with virtual reality
and we're limited to what emerging nations
and I think right now what imagination is still very constrained by real life.
So it's very hard to imagine a world that is not physically constrained.
You know
and be in my generation in my be the next generation after us that actually has a much more free mind to imagine
because I see in right now our own developing the technology that we have now freed up our minds
but the steam really can do. Again the ability to go or whatever that they are.
It just opens again at a time in human history that that is completely different from everything else that we have
right now and you know here I am I've been doing this since I was a youngest you then
and people say hey don't you get bored and I know because you know a.
The difference for example with let's say maybe a biology is that he spends his
or her entire career looking for a particular drug to cure at the C.S.
You know I haven't spent my entire life in one hundred S. So sense of different reality is a spirit and says worlds.
I've seen things that I've never seen before. I've been in places that I cannot be otherwise.
You know I've been in fifteenth century India for example
and I have participated in some religious ritual that doesn't happen anymore.
In real life you know we have been into the future
and trying to figure out how life in Mars is going to be you know I have traveled through galaxies.
I had gone down inside a plant cell and I actually traveled inside a water molecule
and see for the synthesis from the you know.
No I don't because I believe many many life whirls on the system in a way and I were there to see.
But I cannot physically this business that you know so to me is really exciting you know
and like I say what are we going to do one hundred years from now two hundred years from now.
I don't know I mean it's hard to imagine because again.
Could you imagine writing a water molecule and follow the water molecule inside a plant so you can imagine that.
Well we've done it you know and we've done that with team in our lab for example you know.
So it's sometimes it feels like I haven't broken my IRA chains here yet. You know we're trying.
Yeah and to me that's what is exciting to see the little ones you know.
We have a six year old son and to me sometimes watching him. In virtual reality. My own mind.
Sometimes you know because his mind is not constrained as my mind because we have right now.
I think we have four generations concurrently living as a see relates not only to virtual reality
but to technology in general
and again it's a unique time in history because you know all the issues related to health
and quality of life have been are the best in human history.
So now we have people that are living well into their eighty's
and ninety's having a perfectly functional life so we have elderly people that have been their entire life with our
technology and now in their sixty's seventy's eighty's are facing technology.
So when you put those people in the right your reality. Is my best way to describe it is just adorable.
It's just adorable.
They just like to see and they're like oh
and they just they just don't they cannot even comprehend what it is that they're looking at you know.
They're very afraid of movie. They just kind of look around and they're like thank you. D.R.
but That you know people like us you know the next sort of group of people were technology came
when we were ready professionals very young professionals.
So we have to develop our professional life with this technology around us.
So I think we are the Tinkers because we are the ones that are like. How this thing works.
You know what can I do with this thing you know so. So for us.
The mystery is not so much on more of the the vision of what this thing is going to do for the life of the humans for
as the mystery is was under the hood and how this thing works.
You know
and that's really what my generation is really focused on then there's the next generation which is the people that are
now maybe in their twenty's or so you know and this technology came to them when they were kids
but all their kids like teenagers are so so for them it was kind of like.
I have it whatever you know I'm texting I'm doing this and doing that is cool. I can play video games.
So for them is is something that is a cool factor and then you had little ones that are being born into these
and like my son my son because his you know we have research as he's literally been in virtual reality since he was
even I mean I have pictures on him in the little basket as a newborn inside a cave and things like you know.
So so for him is just it's just like a refrigerator is just so so he doesn't wonder about it.
He's not afraid of he's not curious about how it works where he's curious. What happens in here.
You know he's he's perspective this you know he goes into overtime environment
and he just wants to just seems in there.
He doesn't think about how difficult or how comfortable you know he is immediately mentally
and he just wants to be there
and then hysteroscopy a lot of interesting questions because he wants to do things that he cannot do and for him.
That doesn't have any logic. Because again he's mentally they are.
So he has in his mind he has a concept of how to stay in nice to respond to him
and he's not responding to him sometimes because for straight.
Because because he's my niece is is way beyond my mind you know so but he so.
So when when he sees my constraints implemented on the system.
He gets frustrated because he wants to really go a day or
but he said there that I don't understand it you know because I'm still busy looking under the hood.
You know so I think for me in our case we're very fortunate because she is the whole family.
My husband is part of the the same research that I do you know
when our son pretty much leaves with us in the in the lab whenever he's not schooled you know so we have an interesting
perspective on doing this
and in some cases like I say he our little son sometimes opens our minds just because we see his frustrations because
he suspects some things that are not happening.
But we didn't even think about it because we were to be very you know saw.
So this is a she's getting a little older I think it's going to be if he continues being interesting because you know
who knows where Bella been as he grows up.
I think is going to be interesting to see he's on restricted mine and I you mentioned earlier you know.
He might develop different identities that I'm not thinking about you know
but he might decide that you know we just got some face and equipment in our laboratory and he mastered that equipment.
Before any of our students and watching him you seen that particular if we met he was absolutely amazing. The students.
Got the technology to look around. And couldn't see anything to do with it.
He could spend hours days doing things with it. And I we were to do that you know. Is amazing.
It's just amazing to see that.
So I think we have those those different generations
and it's very very interesting you know because again I have my older parents too
and watching them sometimes their reaction is the total opposite.
You know the market strain because they they don't even want to move because they feel they're going to break something
or or they're not sure what to spend you know later once they're somewhere else that we don't even know.
So that's amazing. And he's playing he travels with us.
Sometimes when we do professional events and he actually is in the both know in their minds
and is really really fun watching him explaining this interpretation of our work is just really amazing because in most
cases. He just observes a little bit. But he just takes it to a completely different level immediately not to me.
I mean he doesn't even know how to read but it's just again he's he's my me someone else.
I cannot go there and to constrain. With my own knowledge of the technology to let me go there where he doesn't.
What you mean by.
OH NO HE No no no he doesn't need no he just you know he's not only he I mean we talk about my son because of
when he brings his little friends to the lab sometimes you know it's the same thing.
I mean you know they're a little kindergarten. You know and they.
They again they start doing manipulating the space creating you know their own world.
With a freedom that we don't have you know and they don't know how to read or write
but is not about that understanding of the world or something. You know they grew up with.
So for them is just as normal in the house.
It certainly will be the mind of the universe for the future of course because I mean every every generation needs a
new mindset on not only technology just humanity
and the world you know I mean these are the new minds of the New Universe because the new universe is not going to be
only the universe as we know it today with the planets and the galaxies and all the beautiful formations.
Is a completely leave made less universe because it's going to come out of power so it's new mines Absolutely. What.
Yes that's what I said the New Universe is it doesn't have physical constraints because again we can create it in the
computer there the real universe is still will be there and all the re our program sniper global warning crime.
Social the start.
Those of course those are going to be there and that's outside my expertise to to prepare their word for it
but we might get to the point of saying we will get to the point not of my generation
but I won't get into the point because again we go back to what I was Who are we are not the difference between real
and virtual because we go back to my earlier common people don't differentiate between virtual reality
and augmented reality and I don't I seen this in a sense the same.
Because the virtual reality in the computer with cemented reality you come blend it into the real world.
So so that's really for me where the future were virtual reality
and I meant of reality converge because now your real reality and your virtual reality are intermingled
and not different from each other so.
So again we can be looking out that we know and I know I'm looking at the river
but mental reality I'm I see I don't know some mystical dragon flying by in the head of the birds is my reality because
I want to see dragons flying or running through my window. So I still see the river.
I see the same things you see I see that real trees I see the barges coming down the river
but I have my dragons flying around. That's my reality.
No I think in the definition of again and again we have one makes me me me based whatever I want to be me. You know me.
You know the essence you know because again you can be different things you can be in different places. Again.
Personalities or something like that. You know but that is. You know might be a dominant personality. You know.
I think perhaps that way to look at it is we might have a choice.
I mean right now we don't have a choice me is me is this month whether I like it or not this is.
You this is the one choice. Something like. I was in the end they were saying Richard things.
I thin in my yes maybe he was. Yeah but I can't say for us.
I'm going to be that person that that individual that maybe I don't know
when my hand there have been some supreme individual that is our main character that we decide this is this is the boss
of all my individual's representations and this is the one amazing all the decisions. I don't know like I said to me.
It's hard to envision that this moment because there are.
Again I feel I'm a little bit constraint on what I know I can do for us.
Yeah
but again I thought back to what we have today with the situations with social media you know that there are there are
many that are potentially many myths out there you know because many of us maybe we have one social media persona
appetite are people that have multiple social media personas.
You know and you know I might be talking to you on my social media person now when I'm some young teenager. Go surfing.
You know and you have no way to know you're talking with a fifty something year old woman you know
but behind all those personas. I'm still me making been the supreme me making the decision not to have this.
Kind of the finest of for herself.
Now I know what you mean
but I think you can trust your identities because you are building those identities The problem is with the other
people can't trust your identities.
You are building those identities so I don't see any issues and you are me trust in my own
and it is because I'm defining those I'm building those and making those happening.
So I don't see now have an issue as you know I can I can be a lobster and I totally trust myself as a lobster.
Now you know would you trust me as a lobster I would question you now.
So this more and again going back to the simpler situation with social media is the same thing.
Do you trust that person through social media.
Don't you really don't know who that person is you see what the postings are what the blocks are what they may be fake
pictures that person is not that person is trusting himself or herself because they are building that
but the problem is not so much than the others. And yes there is again that is. We may reach a point where we don't.
And again science fiction has already discussed this heavily in a lot of different books you know where where you get
into the Saturn is reality universes and you get to a point where you don't know which one is the real one anymore
and which one is a dream and which one is. And potentially we can get into that direction.
Again not in the very short term but in a very long term potentially we can go that way.
We would probably neither you or me would be alive by then time but there is there is now.
Yes Then maybe we can create some of that is Stace even though we are physically no longer here
and there is a possibility.
Does that really I'm saying we're going to be in more time in virtual reality maybe we are you know robotics people are
starting to the you can transfer your mind to the Robert our physical body might be gone
but maybe many years from now
when my continually we known ourselves who now you know all these things are out they are for our imaginations to
really explode I guess there's going to be a lot more people out there. Again for us for me.
You know our life or way of living that I have no choice
and some people choose their past mine with no choice in Mass was totally random I came from here and I'm from there
and I'm from there and I landed into these virtual reality thing without.
And knowing when I landed and you know I just enjoy it tremendously
but it was not up plan like I had some students that come with a Betty plan but it just happened.
You know and it's been it's been fun and and it's fun to be able to open the door
and see what happens to the next the next generations that don't have those constraints where they're really come fly
free and and that's and that is when real progress is going to happen right now we're just starting
and we are again sometimes constrained from our want to own our own knowledge today constrain sometimes
and we can think and the new generations that now that she's a matter of fact is not a discovery anymore.
Then they can take it to the next level some as we did from the previous generations from us.
But he patted the practicality. I guess I lost of his very much.
But I think that fundamentally what makes virtual reality to me an exciting science.
Is that there are no rules limiting what we can do.
Again we will go back to the example of our biology so something like that is trying to find a cure for the cease.
She's or her career. T.V. Is bound by the laws of physics. No matter how many ideas they can have a D.N.A.
Of the day it has to have some sort of molecular Bondy in protein something in vitals whatever D.N.A.
Something it has very clear rules of behavior.
The nice thing about virtual reality is we don't have that like I say early dilema is what we can imagine
but we can think we have no physical constraints the physical world.
Does not constrain what we can do in the virtual reality is magic because again I am not bound by the laws of physics.
So I What is magic because here if I want to walk on the ceiling.
I can't because gravity is going to make me fall in virtual reality the nothing prevents me from starting walking out
the wall and walking up the ceiling. It might be a matter of fact you know it's magic.
Because for example I'm here with you right now and in two seconds. I can be in China does my cheek. You know like.
I don't know you can ask my father but I think they're starting more and more when when I started doing this.
Many many years ago they were very worried
and skeptical that I was doing something that was worth anything because of course
when I started it was that the really tinkering times hours that are covered from head to toe in myself in a scuffle
the screwdrivers on my hands all the time you know so but I think over to you. They've seen a lot of.
They've seen how the world has been spread out in a lot of industry in a lot of different parts of society
and I think understanding better. Again the. Their perspective.
Like for them is truly much like I have no idea how you do these funny but it looks great.
So for them is truly truly magic. You know for me again this is magic in the sense that you can just in a split second.
Be somewhere else and again that's somewhat. A reconstruction of a real place or a completely imagination place and.
And you can see sometimes again on the on the little ones you can. You can hear my sound something like this is magic.
I'm doing magic.
You know because he does something about our hands or something and something else happens and of course in real life.
It's impossible to do. It is magic and his magic out because it just chance people you know people.
You know when you go to Disney World.
It's just magical place when people go to virtual reality it's the same feeling
and Changmin like oh this is really nice is fine. Almighty being.
Maybe I'm not I don't know but you know I mean it's what everybody in the valley can believe you know
when like I say I don't I don't believe that if I step out of my virtual bank on the I'm going to fall down the cliff
you know and there are many people at home and they cannot take that a step. You know.
And I think I send a skeptical about that because you know it's in the computer.
Yeah I think I think for something like.
For something that they are talking I SAME MY have to be you know if you look in the history you know every time
there's a new religion or a new goal
or something something very drastic happened in human history that is new god appears you know so.
So might be a possibility for again some massive drastic who knows what happens in human history that Sanny the world
supersedes the physical world in some on that.
and then adopt point maybe there should be maybe some new groups of people that I start creating D.S. You know.
Almighty being that he's never seen or something but I seen with the world as we know it today.
I don't see that happening.
And there's again some Mejor something happens to humanity that they need to believe in something new which is what
really you look at the history of religion that's really what happens.
They don't you got to come up with something that's happened
and there is something knows that people need to hold on to as as we are right now and I don't think that will happen.
I mean. Yes. We can we.
For all we know we can be some computers
or somebody else bill that we are just enjoying a little bit about the life you know I guess.
Yes of course of course you know.
And then we get into the on your menu not do you believe in the Christian God or do believe or not these go
or are you completely and I say stand and all those kinds of things you know.
I think it's more in the really believes my family is traditionally a Catholic family. So we.
I guess belief that we are humans and this is the real reality
and hopefully there will be some other some of the reality on our next stage in life.
Now and I don't have an answer for that I have no idea.
I think that again it's going to be a very very individual life style mindset for that you know same as all that
religion that are some drug.
Jones that are to some people feel very crazy but they have a lot of followers and
and some of their religions we are more comfortable and we are the followers or something.
You know so I think that's just part of human life.
I guess or part of humanity some some of us believe in things and some of us don't believe in things.
I don't think we all collectively will believe one just that one thing. Because the never happen.
You never higher than tired
or believe in them the same thing all together so I seen in virtual reality in my develops culls sake's communities.
Party she's never sure what I call it you know. Maybe you know I mean again same as with religion.
Sometimes you will hear something on television some breach happens and.
You're like I wonder how these people actually follow this you know
and then sometimes you hear some others that you know lie or this is really really good.
You know and maybe somebody else is OK how do you know you are crazy how can you believe in that you know. No.